hey what's up guys it's Rob I hope
you're having a great summer today I'm
going to show you how to make the
origami rose this is a really fun model
to make and it makes for an awesome gift
it was originally designed by Toshi
kazoo Kawasaki and even though it's a
standard rose it's still an advanced
model and I don't recommend it for
beginners if you haven't seen my other
origami tutorials like the paper crane
the origami butterfly the gift box or
even the boomerang I would check those
out first by clicking on any one of
these links what you're going to need
for this tutorial is a piece of standard
printer paper or if you have colored
printer paper that will work fine also
I've split a tutorial into two parts and
this first part covers how to make the
origami Rose base so once you have a
piece of paper or origami paper you're
ready to go
the first thing we need to do is to
convert the printer paper into a square
so we're going to take this corner and
we're going to align the top edge with
the side edge by folding it across once
it's neatly lined up you can make a
crease along this new fold here and I
want you to use your fingernail to make
really sharp creases all throughout the
Rose tutorial because it will make
folding the Rose a little bit easier
then you can remove this excess paper by
either tearing it or cutting it if you
do cut it it will come out a little bit
neater and you'll also have this excess
paper and you want to hold on to this
excess paper because this is what we're
going to use to make the stems of the
origami roses so once you have this
paper you can then unfold it and you'll
notice we have a crease going this way
in the paper so now we could take the
upper left corner and fold it down to
the lower right corner line it up as
best you can and then make a crease
so when you open up the paper you'll now
see that you have an X in it now you can
take the top edge of the paper and fold
it down to the bottom edge of the paper
and again just make a crease and use
your fingernail so when you open it
you'll see you have an X and a
horizontal line in the middle what you
want to do now is to take the top and
bottom edges and fold it on to this
midline that we now have so take the top
edge and fold it down to that midline
and make a crease and do the same with
the bottom edge
so when you unfold it you'll now see
that we have four horizontal sections
we're going to do the same going this
way now so just rotate the paper so that
these lines are vertical and then you
could do the same by taking the top edge
folding the paper down in half and make
a crease
open it up and then once again fold the
top and bottom edges onto the midline
so once you unfold now you will notice
that you have an X in the paper and you
also have 16 squares in the paper as
well once you have a piece of paper that
looks like this we're going to take the
bottom half of the paper and fold it up
to the top half and make sure everything
is nice and flat for the next fold I'd
like you to just visualize the distance
between the bottom end here and this
first horizontal fold this distance here
now if you split that distance into
thirds we're going to fold up the very
bottom third of the paper so to help you
visualize this I have drawn on another
model now by all means you do not have
to draw on a model to understand this
however I've just done this to make it
easier for you to see we're going to
fold up the very bottom third of that
distance so you're going to fold it up
just like that and as you'll see the
amount that we have folded up this space
here is the same space same distance as
the distance from the edge to that fold
there so we're going to fold the bottom
edge up until the distance that we have
folded up is equal to the distance that
we have remaining to that first
horizontal fold just like that so as
you'll see it's about the same this
distance is about the same as the
distance that we have remaining so it
looks like half-and-half
okay then you can make a crease along
that new fold and then you can unfold
everything
and as you'll see we now have those two
new folds here now we're going to do the
same the other way so just rotate the
paper take the bottom half fold it up to
the top half and then again we're going
to fold the bottom edge up
and as you'll see you should see little
squares here when you do that make a
crease on this portion as well then when
you unfold everything you'll notice that
it looks like this
okay so I've drawn four lines on those
new creases that we've just created
those four creases need to be Mountain
folds so what you do is you just fold
downwards on that crease here and then
you can also fold downwards on this
crease and now there are mountain folds
but in the middle the this crease here
needs to be a valley fold so a valley
fold just means that it's folded upwards
like that so a mountain fold means that
you're folding downwards on it a valley
fold means that it's folded upwards so
you have a mountain of valley and a
mountain and that creates what looks
like an M so just close those two
creases together and then run your
fingernail against both of them and then
do the same with the other two fold
downwards on this one fold downwards on
this one here and then just join the two
by pushing downwards in the middle to
create a valley fold in the middle and
then just run your fingernail against
those two also so it should look like
this now we're going to flip the model
over and as you'll see I drew a little
box with a cross in it here so what
we're going to do is we're going to fold
on one of the diagonals it doesn't
matter which one so just fold like that
and I'm going to hold it I'm going to
hold the model now on the left side of
this cross here so I want to hold it
like that and as you'll see this is kind
of sticking up here I'm going to push
directly on the corner of this little
box I have here so if I push here like
that these are now Valley folds okay and
what you're going to do is you're going
to lift the
corner up in between these two folds
here what you want to first do though is
you're going to push on that little line
there so you want to push on that line
and you're going to pinch these two
folds together just like that
and now what you're going to do is
you're going to lift up this corner in
between these two folds so going to lift
up this corner in between those two
folds just like that okay and then just
give it a good crease and then you're
going to do the same with the left side
now they're directly opposite so as
you'll notice you can't really push
there if it's not open so what you do is
you're just going to push outwards on it
like this and then all you need to do is
to poke or push on the corner of this
little box there you might need to just
unfold some parts of it if it gets a
little wrinkled so it should look like
this and then you're going to push right
in the corner and you're going to
squeeze these two edges together now
make sure that these are valley folds in
the corner and then what you need to do
is you just need to lift up this corner
in between those two folds like that
and then just flatten flatten it out
like that and you should have something
that looks like this okay so what we're
going to do now is we're going to take
this little tip here and we're going to
fold it down so that it is flush with
the rest of the triangle here so just
fold it down like this until it's flush
with the rest of the triangle just like
that then you can unfold it and then
we're going to take the tip and we're
going to fold it directly onto that line
onto that fold that we just made so just
take the tip and fold it down like that
and then you can just crease it really
good also and then you could unfold that
part too now we're going to do is we're
going to pick up the model and as you'll
see this is where we tucked in this
corner here and this is where we tucked
in that corner we're going to do the
same with this corner and this corner
now so just hold it like this and you
want to take these two mountain folds
now the ones that are sticking up and
you're going to squeeze these two
together and now you should be able to
lift this corner up in between those two
so just pinch these two together like
that and this is kind of forming what
looks like an X here so just pinch these
two together now lift this up and then
just give it a nice crease then these
two you can also pinch together like
that and then you could lift up this
corner in between those two creases
so when you're done you should have
something that looks like this so what
we're going to do now is we're going to
flatten the model out and we're also
going to flatten these little mountain
folds out when we do that we want to
give them a counterclockwise spin so
this mountain fold is going to go up
this mountain fold is going to go to the
left this one's going to go down and
this one is going to go to the right so
what you need to do is just give this
little X in the middle a
counterclockwise spin like that and then
gently push down on everything so you'll
see here this fold should be down this
one should be to the right this one
should be up and this one should be to
the left just like that and when you do
that this X should sort of stick up in
the middle and what you're going to do
now is you're going to flatten this out
to do that we're going to pull on two
opposite parts of the X gently so just
gently push down on it like this and
then do the same with the other two and
it will sort of inflate or bubble up and
then what you can do is just gently push
down on it until it flattens out and
turns into a square so just push on that
it doesn't matter if it's a little
wrinkled it's not going to make a big
difference in the end but try to get it
as neat as possible and flatten it out
so it should look something like this so
this is known as the rose base and now
you have these flaps flattened out
remember they're going in a
counterclockwise direction and when you
flip it you'll also notice you have four
flaps here as well thanks for watching
part 1 of my tutorial for the origami
rose I hope you found it helpful now you
able to complete the row space to get to
part two all you need to do is to either
click the link on my hand or click one
of the links in the video description or
series playlist above before you go
don't forget to leave me a comment below
any questions feedback or video
responses post them below and I'll be
sure to take a look at them also if you
enjoy the video give me a thumbs up by
clicking the like button down to the
left and if you want to follow my videos
or subscribe for further notification
all you need to do is to click the
subscribe or follow button above